no we look at whether or not there's
sufficient evidence does it demonstrate
crimes being committed and is it in the
public interest is paying
public officials a crime it can be yes
and our guidance which we publish the
revised guidance today makes it very
clear it can still be a crime how much
does this all cost
um for us it's cost 1.3 million
but it's about making sure that we
really
look at the evidence properly we've got
to look at cases that comes first from
the police and scrutinize them and
actually if you look at the court of
appeal judgment nowhere does it
criticize the fact that we have brought
any of these prosecutions nor have any
of them been stopped they've all gone to
the jury as well i mean you don't want
to bring prosecutions and have this sort
of failure right do you
um we look at reasonable expectation as
i understand it it's got to be a
realistic prospect of conviction um
which we have thought that there has
been um following the course of appeal
judgment which was only two weeks ago we
have looked again at whether or not our
guidance is right we supplemented that
guidance and we have looked again or
i've looked again actually
over the last two weeks at all the cases
that have been outstanding and some of
those we have changed well i wanted to
ask you about that because this is about
sun journalists it was about payments to
officials other news organizations and
newspapers have been uh involved in
phone hacking there are a number of
people still on bail number of people
still possibly facing the prospect of
prosecutions i mean how many of them are
you actually going to go ahead with
um we have said today we are prosecuting
still we are still conducting
prosecutions against some public
officials um and there are still some
journalists who are facing prosecution
for um payment
um i think there are three um and
obviously we can't get into the facts of
those because they wait try to do in
those cases those are the ones that
we've already reviewed so we've reviewed
all the cases that are currently waiting
trial under operation elfton
um and there are only a couple of cases
that's very different and that's not
altered at all so they still remember so
we can expect there will be some big
prosecutions there can we um those that
have been charged um will continue in
those cases i mean what we're very clear
about is that we make these decisions
very quickly because we appreciate that
people are waiting trial and obviously
that's stressful what do you say
to uh we saw that son journalist there
who's just been found not guilty about
the way he was treated was there a need
ever for dawn raids and putting people
on police bail for three years um that's
obviously a matter for the police
investigations are down to them that's
not um what the prosecution service do
you can take a view can't you um we look
at the evidence and we decide whether or
not you should be treated like that um
it's entirely an operational matter for
the police how they go about their
investigations
but they are as it were catching your
victims surely you have a view on how
those victims are treated um well
they're not victims
so they're
the police decide they're operationally
independent from us
and we will give them advice on the
charging and then take the cases through
to the court of course there will be
people looking at this the other way who
will feel
looking at your decision on
um
greville janna yesterday not to go ahead
with the prosecution there that people
who are powerful or well connected
including journalists can get away with
it in a way that others can't well they
they're very different scenarios and
very different decisions for different
reasons
and that's absolutely not the case um we
have previously been criticized for
taking prosecutions against what was
seen to be powerful high-profile people
we look at each case on its merits it
doesn't matter who it is we'll look at
the evidence whether or not it's in the
public interest
and who that person that we're looking
at doesn't actually play any part in our
decision making has been quite a lot of
controversy since you took over your job
do you feel under pressure at all um
so long as i'm convinced i'm making the
right decisions um and we are abiding by
the guidance and the code and then
that's what i'm here to do um i'm not
here to make popular decisions i'm here
to make the right decision as to whether
you feel under pressure
i always feel under pressure to make the
right decisions and that's what
is really important to me that we make
the right decisions and finally this
word witch hunt has been used about the
investigations into particularly news
group journalists following the
phone hacking affair do you think it's
fair to use that term
no i don't think it's fair there has
been in public inquiries there was
obviously a lot of concern there was a
very thorough police investigation and
then we're duty-bound to look at that
investigation and decide whether or not
to bring any prosecutors looking at the
other crimes in the world it's worth the
money isn't it
um
we certainly think so we haven't been
criticized by the courts bringing those
prosecutions um and we continue to keep
them under review so um i think we were
right to do so and we're right to make
the decision that we have done now